so uh also here's something that's  pretty big right now uh i don't know if  you guys knew this support for the  republican party the gop just  skyrocketed really this is huge over the  last year the party preference shifted  among americans uh i think this is the  biggest shift uh largest it's a 14 point  swing it's the largest in gallup's  history wow ever  history in a one-year period of time  yeah so q1 2021 40 uh of uh voters uh  favored republicans compared to 49  favoring democrats okay  now it's switch that's q1 q4 same year  47  favoring republicans and 42  that's a 14 point swing  within a year looks like it's going to  be a good year yeah i obviously love  midterms baby and what are you going to  say now what are you going to be like  well rashford's done but okay how about  gallop well they're not legitimate snope  says maybe